[Music]  since childhood I have been fascinated  with language I've invented my own you  invented an entire life [ __ ] yes I made  stories legends tell me a story in any  language you want stop jealous  the journeys we take to prove ourselves  about adventures we should form a club a  brotherhood changed the world through  the power of art music poetry and what  about talking I want to write something  it's about magic beyond anything anyone  who's ever fought before  what it means to love to be loved  [Music]  whoa  [Applause]  we all of the wisdoms at language I had  to tell you mr. talking but never come  across anything like it  this is more than just a friendship it's  an alliance an invincible alliance a  fellowship  [Music]  [Music]